[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL: No, the flamingos
need to be green.
Wait, what do you mean, you
can't have a functioning
DeLorean replica on stage?
SPEAKER: Paul, we
need those Tesla coils
for the after party.
PAUL: Just give me a
minute to shoot this promo.
[SIGH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMP Conf is coming to Amsterdam
on February 13 and 14,
with two days chock-full of
talks by the AMP community,
and plenty of opportunities
to meet like-minded developers
and designers who care
about building best
in class, user-first websites.
Naturally, we come with tons
of news and announcements
related to AMP's
developer experience.
We've also got companies
like Reddit and Airbnb
talking about their technical
journeys, learnings,
and implementation details.
Plus, you'll learn
more about how
AMP is accelerating
the WordPress ecosystem
and influencing the
web platform at large.
AMP Conf is happening
in less than six weeks,
and I'd love to see you there.
Tickets don't cost
anything, and we'll still
have a bunch available.
So come apply for a
spot on ampproject.org.
But if you can't
make it in person,
subscribe to the
AMP channel to be
notified about the live stream.
If you're a developer
or a designer who
is committed to beautiful
user experiences,
come see what AMP has to
offer at AMP Conf 2018.
See you in Amsterdam.
[MUSIC PLAYING]